the trump administration is moving to
break up facebook excellent news
the federal government and 48 attorneys
general
filed twin lawsuits against facebook on
wednesday
seeking to potentially break up the big
tech giant and restrict
future business practices the federal
trade commission is here
attorneys general from 46 states plus dc
plus guam are challenging specifically
the way they're challenging this
is facebook's acquisition of instagram
in 2012 and 2014
when 2014 they acquired whatsapp these
lawsuits
are trying to force facebook to notify
the federal government of any
acquisitions
worth 10 10 million or more
they're not just pursuing section 230
the way that
facebook and other big tech giants have
abused a special legal protection
that they have from a 1990s era internet
law
though they should do that too they're
not just pursuing fraud
the way that that facebook and big tech
have been able to
get a critical mass in the public square
uh they're also going after them
uh with antitrust they're also going
after them
for acquiring companies in a way that's
that's illegal this is good news
glad to see there's a little bipartisan
support here
we need to do it the only conservative
and really more of a libertarian
argument against going after facebook
and i think it's weak even on
libertarian grounds but the only
argument is well
if you allow the government to
police facebook then the left might
start censoring you
like they're already doing through
facebook okay i think
if the risk is so right now here's the
plus side here's the pros for breaking
up facebook
facebook is censoring us and they
probably threw a presidential election
to the left
by actively suppressing very relevant
serious news that even the left is now
admitting serious
because it won't affect their electoral
prospects
so the pros are we can
stop those people from throwing
elections to the left and the con
is by empowering the government to do
this and power they already have
the left might censor us and suppress us
and
tilt elections in their favor so there's
no risk whatsoever
all the reason to do it and i applaud
the trump administration for doing that
i hope we can
get that going quickly